[Music]
all right take a look at this girl right
here imagine that you're on the plane
sitting next to her she show me magic
yeah that's what oh my God she's not
doing magic is that
$100 me make this disappear she looks
like a magician if you had to sit on a
plane next to a magician would you like
ask to change seats would you ask him
like all right bro please stop I
definitely would I wouldn't have to
change Stu show me tricks the whole time
like yo show teach me how to do it
that's so cool all she has is a fake
thumb you're like I don't want to see
the fake I know I don't want the [__]
no ball trick either H like the Spencers
that's level one magic I'm like can you
give me more food yeah did the guys
watch for me that's what I want so the
so imagine that she's next to you on a
plane right she's um she's super drunk I
believe she's Russian she looks unw
she's totally belligerant wilding out
people can't control her and then she
forcibly pulls your pants down and is
trying to forcibly give you head oh no
the hores and then what would you do
would you do what would you do well
first I wouldn't know what else to do I
just might say oh no I would have to
have a hard conversation with my Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ I'll be like
what's happening you know in my head I
guess it's going to shut her up guys
I'll take it from here in my head I want
to think like yeah I'm the cool [__]
swaave [__] that be like yeah
you suck dick you know but in reality
I'd be like please no please please
leave me alone I would have know if I
could get hard please please please yeah
do you think you get hard I don't know
if I get hard like no no please leave me
alone I don't I don't want anything to
do with yeah and I and and there'll be
so many people watching i' be so nervous
I be so nervous be I'd be scared I'd be
scared I just hope she doesn't use teeth
oh yeah that's that's a hard um I would
yeah that's weird cuz if someone was
drunk and crazy why would you let them
even why would you run the risk yeah why
would she that might be something she
does on a r so she might be good you
know what but you guys are not Heroes
like me because you guys are kind of
guys when the terrorist took over the
plane on 911 you would just well except
for Anthony cuz he doesn't know that
anything happen but then all of you guys
would just been like compliant I'm the
guy that would stand up and say hey look
I'll take it for the team I'll shut her
up keep her calm yeah yeah yeah does
your shirt say fear of Mom I don't want
to do it I don't yes it does healthy
fear of mom yeah so that's exactly what
happened I don't want to do it but the
guy just like hey guys I'll shut her up
yeah that's exactly what happened she
basically in incom me she started
forcing this dude he at first he was
like no stop stop stop yeah and then res
this where this he's like no oh no oh no
and then she ends up getting his pants
down and she starts sucking his dick and
the guy's like no and then he's just
like all right okay fine he come to it
he's like oh no for the team crew that
was originally like trying to get her
off they just like stopped and they just
let her cuz she was finally quiet yeah
they just like a baby that's crying the
whole they let her finish it yeah they
let her finish it from a police
perspective he did deescalate the
situation is everybody happy it's really
just her boyfriend and they just staged
is that a porno dude it really says um
seen por like surprisingly the flight
attendants waited until the end of the
action and only then moved valyria
further away her name is Valeria and
then um is Valeria she got Valeria and
steel you know mean she got valarian
disease he was like thank you any pay
her she's like that's it that's it
that's what she's doing why what's the
context with the picture why is she
doing that oh I'll tell you that in a
second magic trick does it say if she's
a swallower or no yeah that's the magic
trick it's to be assumed it's to be
assumed that's happened to you before
they end up restraining her they end up
restraining her to one side of the plane
and then they they uh deputed a a guy to
like hold her like keep her in that and
that guy the next thing you know he's
gonna oh he goes lady stay here he's
like don't worry guys I'll handle this
don't worry about it he's like hey like
what's going on
you she's super drunk and like trying to
smoke a vape and like scratching at the
uh flight attendants and stuff um and
then what happens is she tries to pay
like the flight attendants like that 100
bucks to like I don't know like as a
bribe to get out of my face yeah and
then they they uh throw it in the trash
and then she ends up emptying the whole
trash bin on the plane to like get it
out yeah why did they throw $100 in a
trash why didn't they why didn't they
throw her off the [__] plane I
watched a lady walk up to the to the
door where the pilot is and she knocked
on it cuz she was pissed that we were
sit in the tarmac forever and they threw
her ass off the plane she didn't even
give anybody a blow job or nothing yeah
she didn't offer they they she gives a
guy a [__] she they let her finish
and then they move her these are like
the coolest [__] Airline people ever
is this spirit and had even says that
she demanded hot water and then poured
it on the floor that means they're
giving it to
her wow I don't understand I'm going to
fly them every time I don't know hoping
for a [__] he's going to [__]
create a problem on that it just says
it's petta petta Airlines a Boeing 737
this sounds like a Russian airline think
it's like through Moscow have POA POA
from a a flight a tourist flight from
antalia wow okay so they're just chill
ass people they're probably just like ah
just Russian Behavior we're russan this
is good marketing but nobody ever heard
of this Airline before when they landed
the police came and escorted her away
and then everyone was clapping and then
she told the cop I won't go anywhere
with a sucker Like
You Famous Last Word and then all the
cops busted
afterwards dude that's a good strategy
though '90s action movie quote if you're
in trouble and you could pull out a
[__] as like a last ditch effort
that's that's a good move I think get
out of anything do BU of guys go that's
true cuz the guys will like they'll
think about stop no okay I guess you can
yeah yeah it's like that every single
time I guess you can like it's still
scary to me how you can trust that it
would go okay like yeah cuz she might
bite it that's what I'm saying she might
just be
like at the same time though think about
how much work it is to like take the
guy's par like you could easily stop
somebody or get out of the way just like
oh
oh pretending to stop me what if he was
wearing sweat it's cuz the flight hit
it's like remain seated with your seat
belt on every time we've ever gotten
your every time any of us every time any
of us have ever gotten a [__] yeah
you there's like a little moment where
like you don't know how this is going to
go like because it's a first timer there
a moment of distrust yeah you don't know
she could be a biter she could be all
kinds of stuff you don't know but you
have to see let her do her thing she or
he thank you but if you're drunk and
that's your default move you're probably
you're probably good at it what what you
say if you're drunk and that's your
default move you're probably a season
you're probably good you're probably
very good she clearly is they let her
finish what would you specifically do if
you were the guy in this situ but the
cool Nick not like the regular scared
Nick yeah black man I can't even imagine
that [__] B is a simp for Nick's
black Bel I've never heard anybody talk
Nick won't even talk about the black
belt as much Bart Bart's like such such
a huge
achievement as as she's G me as she's as
she's trying to do me up i' be like I
don't know if you know this but like I
got my black belt last Saturday you know
I would tell her that I would like throw
it in there she does that make your dick
harder yeah like what do you think it is
true though like what if you had to do
it for the good of the
flight if she's like if you don't let me
do this I'm taking this plane down
you're like all right see he's a mar you
guys don't know what a hero looks like
cuz you wouldn't step up yeah yeah yeah
you would step up every time hell yeah I
have to what if it was like a huge Burly
Abdul Abdul rahee nah no why it's you
take one for the team princip about
taking it for the team being a hero
she's a blonde
okay that's true I didn't think about
that you know what that's a very good
point come on man you don't want to save
the plane you wouldn't do it you
wouldn't go that far to save the lives
of that many people were they in the air
yeah they were in the air man legit like
save the lives of like 200 people all
you got to do is get a [__] from a
Burly dude from like Zang G from Street
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah he's to use his
teeth and he's going down only if I get
to hold the girl's
hand oh so's G to be's going to be like
all right baby go get your dick sucked
and you're
like no don't look don't
look and then after two seconds by's
like and you have you have to finish too
you can't just you have to grunting like
a big my God Lives there's children on
the plan so you have to go somewhere
mentally do they have facial hair can
Gio be can Gio be in Bart's ear being
like they got a black
Bel oh oh think that would help that'll
finish so fast like
describe describe the black Tak so many
decades but he got it in five years
wa this reminds me of a time I got
massaged by a man what why is it similar
because uh at first I was like oh I kind
of feel weird about a man just rubbing
me all over right
and the best though but then me bar and
J were just like we got to we're just
going to get a massage we're [__]
sore and then we just walked in and it
was like one of those places the Chinese
style where it's just everybody everyone
can see each other and then they don't
they don't choose [__] up the office
dude you know how Ryan spent all this
time making this place [__] beautiful
hey that looks sick leave it black belt
my ass it looks cool you don't even know
you don't have situational awareness
what kind of black belt are you you
don't know everything B Voice sign you
got a basil bar dude you don't even know
where your [__] peripherals are these
are new chairs I thought black Bel had
eyes behind the back of their hands dude
only when I'm sitting down on the
floor it was bound to happen your Black
Belt being the scapegoat and reason for
everything that happens now is funny
though I don't even watch this thing so
you got massaged and you didn't so we
win and then you can usually request
male female whatever and then this dude
like a Asian
just and I'm all
like and then I was like oh no no no I
I'm going to wait for it he goes no no
no everybody everybody and then and then
and then he was like yeah yeah yeah and
then I was like all right I'm just going
to sit down but I want a lady and then
as soon as he just went this to my
temple I melt it and I was like oh [__]
hook me up dad hook me up Daddy okay
hook me up then he started suing his
dick yeah yeah yeah yeah he went like oh
I hook you up child man suck
dick I you
up so we we're talking about bar just
nutting while Gio's holding his hand
Whispering Nick Blackbeard black belt
[__] and Joe's like this reminds me of
the time I got massaged by a
man